people are really shocked that never had
cooked before so I'm actually really
excited to see what all the fuss is
about I'm a big Pepsi fan and I don't
know about trying to coca-cola
I just never drink soda when I was
growing up diabetes is a big problem in
my family and my mom was very strict
about sugar I grew up with diet coke I
kind of don't know that I'll be able to
even get past whatever sugar there is in
it I'm kind of scared this is a big deal
I feel like I need pancakes to pour it
on it's little thing it's almost like
rancid barbecue sauce okay never have
eaten it again I don't know why people
drink this that's actually pretty good
give me that burping sensation I love
tomorrow it tastes like a bird a good
birth though it's the aftertaste the
aftertaste is worse than the actual
initial taste I've been in a long-term
relationship with Pepe and I will never
leave him the college people say they
don't like this I think they're probably
like I'm very happy to know what all the
fuss is about now I don't feel like a
black sheep among American this is
pretty good stuff I've had a lot of
better other first oh man this you may
have opened Pandora's box here if my mom
knew I was drinking then she would be
very disappointed